[Music]
it went a girlfriend news that is
calling why words why would you want
that it's good because you get all the
good things about a girlfriend beat all
the [ __ ] I was thinking like you get
all the other stuff submitted by
bringing your own boba a new app was
released that let users rent warmed up
secondhand sex dolls that's a hooker
nice you we should invest in like 50 of
them and then rent them out and make
money so it's like a uber but a [ __ ]
hmm and we can handle it with us next
thought you already [ __ ] it and then
somebody else wants to [ __ ] it so
non-monogamous sex doll [ __ ] we can
call it rent oho so they're players they
need what you have come the the [ __ ] is
sex dolls there's like a perfect circle
I don't know my sex dolls I'm sorry Real
Dolls can you mouth [ __ ] them yeah I
didn't know that these are the the ones
that looked like Xena won't be a
princess Wonder Woman yeah he was fine
yeah so this sex toy company called
touch they release an app called shared
girlfriend I would have [ __ ] Yvonne
that's the most uncreated name ever
human think of anything else can think
of a pun those hoes don't know how to
dress
the other name was polite turtle or
something gonna be like a real
girlfriend app like you pretend to be on
a date but this one you can actually
[ __ ] I thought it's just called escorts
not like a rubber escort do we talk
about an app where you get to like
message and AI and pretend that it's
your girlfriend don't you remember
reporting that I remember talking about
that [ __ ] I don't know I don't know just
for the companionship yeah you know what
yeah I guess [ __ ] weird so anyways
this uh what they were offering is a
life-size silicon
cause each are worth about $1,500 they
were marketed as like Chinese Korean and
Russian looking dolls along with Wonder
Woman and so first one of them look
Chinese or Korean to me I don't know a
black real doll maybe the thing black
people don't need help
guess why well maybe an Asian guy has a
fetish for black people
I don't know I feel like if I rented one
of these the first thing I would do is
smell the [ __ ] areas oh my god they did
a good job of cleaning it wait this
doesn't smell like Lysol they didn't
reclaim this and then I probably get
like a q-tip and go yeah look at it
that's true I wonder how they clean the
vagina yeah look how many people have
come to know it hatched or do you like
take it out I just imagine you like
shining a black light over you just see
although yeah this [ __ ] splatter like
all over the chest that's not like a
nice day they look heavy oh that doesn't
let a crane girl there you can rent
these ladies these dolls look at how
skinny her arm and Ferrell there's a
Korean girl I never see fat real dolls I
don't know maybe they don't like them
for some reason maybe there's a lot of
high demand or maybe the shipping causes
expensive heavy ass [ __ ] doll Oh
genius what if she comes deflated and
you can fill her up with water and
customize how big you want her copies
company it's a high ram with a bigger
booty is yeah so with a $1,200 deposit
is that a real man right there yeah yeah
what's crazy so first they have to give
a $1,200 deposit and then there's like a
daily fee that's not the whole price
twelve involves is just a deposit is the
deposit so you can rent it so then
they're having options where you can
have the option of having the doll
warmed up before it being delivered to
you which I don't know what that means
but they do
that is a is that a black I don't know
duffle Indian weekend
yeah a stripper outfit on point though
oh [ __ ] China by the way I don't know if
I mentioned that oh man no I'm not
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that thing's gonna
explode on my dick look at that [ __ ]
ass man
yes that arch is real the bottom the
user gets to keep owww that's always
trying to get a trouble
also you can change the face and the
person oh you could customize the dogs
I'm gonna sing you the parts yes oh
they'll send you the dog but with like a
brand new [ __ ] [ __ ] an [ __ ] oh I
see cos a vagina detaches bottom bottom
oh and they get to keep it
I don't know I'm a pervert but I don't I
don't like this I wonder how worsen if
you already have that peace bill okay
and I'd have the but peace can I just
get the blonde and then they send you
the part I think so I rather [ __ ] a dead
girl the fresh one this is weird why are
you're kidding doh please tell me you're
kidding we get it but if I had to choose
the tunic okay like okay sorry dead a
long time guys have no self-respect okay
like I I don't know I don't know it's
just yeah so weird it's like it's it's
it is like a giant flashlight though
yeah the ball compass is a little bit
weird here [ __ ] your dolls weird for
[ __ ] it that don't blame the [ __ ]
blame the guy that invented this hey I
don't want to I'm just saying like hey
if someone says would you rather eat
diarrhea or dog [ __ ] maybe dog [ __ ] not
human diarrhea that's what I'm saying
though it's like I'm not you know it's
like you don't say I rather [ __ ] a real
real girl I think you say like if it
which is the lesser evil to him or I
guess
I'm trying to help my homie out right
now okay funny thing is that Joe put the
ultimate on himself
yeah the [ __ ] dead girl huh in a
situation where like he's being held
captive like [ __ ] the doll or I will
make you [ __ ] dead girl well I mean
you know yeah guys like no I mean you
can do something don't know you're like
no dog doll oh god yeah he gives him me
optionally and then like his captors
just like this is [ __ ] I'd rather [ __ ] a
dead girl than a dog that's a lot of
work for masturbation dead girl than a
dog yeah who would you rather [ __ ] I
don't want to [ __ ] a dead dog that's
nice because tomorrow he'll be like
something like he'll make us feel like
[ __ ] or something
just you know terrible be normal you
know that's so disgusting get it I don't
know you're weird
I don't know I'm weird look no one
[ __ ] a real doll a real doll
I don't want some [ __ ] look I don't
want to come out saying like I know be
nice guys if I fought if I did some
necrophilia they'll be [ __ ] awesome
ok a doll I suppose it at all yeah I'm
just saying like this is really weird
like what's what's what's kinda weird
but like a little bit better a human
being I mean no you know it's really
weird I read a headline recently worried
there was this brothel that had one sex
doll and that one doll had way more
customers in the human the human process
I don't know good this is obviously the
new trend and I'm discriminating maybe I
need to try it myself and then I go you
know what I was wrong this is awesome
maybe because those guys are shy and
they don't want girls potentially
laughing at their dick so they feel
safer with a doll or what if all the
girls out the brothel are hella busted
compared to the doll chill
that's true I didn't even think about
that it's true anyways back to this
whole you're just dog shaming over there
he's not the other girls are jealous of
a doll they hate her you try to kill her
at night Stacy pull your arms out was
shut down or the rental why why could
it's hurting wait how long was it
running for only a couple days down
because prostitution is illegal
no because um Chinese authorities like
they were actually taken to the local
police station and they were being
interviewed and they were saying that
this whole like sex doll displayed to
cos er beat they're just saying it was
too vulgar for society so then that's
why we shut it down I mean they are
spent maybe in China it's not the same
like now their moral compass is weird
yeah but you can't have a rubber doll
bent over like come on you know hunting
sharks and cutting off fins but you
can't have a rubber doll around yeah man
whatever no and then in the article they
also say that the company agreed to
comply with the request of you know
shutting everything down noting however
that sex itself is not vulgar it sound
like this would be a hit in Japan it is
is pornea we go in China like I don't
know I don't know the time that's a good
question as a good question have you
guys ever seen Chinese play no no we're
seen Chinese even tried searching for I
should probably try searching I've never
even seen Vietnamese poignant have you
seen Kareem oh no I've only seen
Japanese yeah I thought porns illegal in
Korea I think it is ask my friends no no
that's not remember remember I told you
my friend works at a no choking no
choking in Korean porns maybe they
change the laws I once saw a gang bang
of a Korean girl and masked Korean men
but I don't know the title just said
Korean so yeah they didn't speak
American produced - yeah but they're
definitely not of the Asian American
type I never seen alien porn either I
have really yeah it's interesting like a
Kama Sutra one yeah
Ballu that way don't you wish she was
she Indian Middle Eastern the one we did
an article about her she was she won
like an award oh she's always wearing
like a Middle Eastern I was Khalifa
or something you did an article about it
on Jake in you we have mutual friends
with her all we do I'll tell you who
later did she still do poor maybe she
might have retired I think she did
retire oh we're in a war she got death
threats because she was she was such a
with she was sucking dick with uh with
the hijab quality of porn women though
are starting to really change like
there's like glam not glam porn but like
they look like Instagram models or like
girl next door and normal like hot girls
that are you know having sex and like as
a attractive couples so it's not not no
longer like yeah that's what are you
weird yes yeah yeah it's yeah and then
there's and there's they don't have that
pornstar look you know so I was like dad
this is pretty cool Lucas anyway it's
film too and shot it's like pretty cool
its cinematic yeah it crane shots and I
saw porn vlog once what it's pretty
interesting
a blonde corn vlog yeah so like I think
some porn stars or Senate akin to like
vlogging - oh and then I saw I think
like a two hour porno you guys are
intrigued who out what the hell is to
our porn element no way is these two
hours and she's like hell that guys just
made my [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Adams doing
right now go over that hey you wanna
[ __ ] and it did so she starts [ __ ]
doctor in the vlog like this is the
blogging but now porno star
Oh gonna go [ __ ] jet skiing and not
look me and she goes like the pier hey
you want me to suck your dick
sure no it's not it's definitely YouTube
that's too long like but it's the vlog
format for pornos but it's meant to be a
porno I'm not meant to be a porno or
maybe it's meant to be able that sounds
exciting
cuz now it's like the life of that porn
star but you can tell she's probably
playing it up because
there aren't too many boning sections
you're not gonna watch it of course you
want to see you're doing laundry or some
[ __ ] they don't come for a comedy yeah
hey guys I hope you enjoyed that episode
of just kidding news and if there's a
story that you guys want us to talk
about go ahead down into our description
box below and there's a link there where
you can submit articles for the next
video click right up here
[Music]